when you work on the NCIS team your life
is always on the line and many beloved
characters have paid the ultimate price
in pursuit of justice let's take a look
at what some of these actors have been
up to since they're NCIS character went
kaput played by Sasha Alexander former
Secret Service agent Caitlin Todd was
fiercely intelligent and could easily
craft detailed psychological profiles of
her suspects on the spa she was smart
but not immortal in season two she's
caught off guard by a terrorist cell in
a warehouse and ultimately assassinated
by a sniper this grisly development
caught viewers completely by surprise
especially since she'd already been shot
once during the episode a bulletproof
vest saved the day the first time around
but alas she wasn't so lucky the second
time since leaving NCIS alexander landed
the plum role of Medical Examiner dr.
Maura Isles on another crime drama
Rizzoli and Isles she also had a
recurring role on shameless as Helene
Runyon and has appeared in supporting
roles in films like yes-men and he's
just not that into you played by Alan
Dale former NCIS director Tom Morrow
still felt a certain responsibility
towards his old team after retiring from
the job but that commitment ultimately
cost him his life still he really knew
his stuff just listen to this she worked
at the Russian embassy in Turkey the
raid went pear-shaped she was killed not
ideal but mission accomplished meaning
in the season 13 episode returned to
sender
Gibbs visits Morrow's home and finds him
very much dead in his office we later
find out he was killed by Trent kort a
former CIA operative who proved to be
the worst kind of traitor
once Morrow's time on NCIS was up Dale
joined the cast of the dynasty reboot in
2007 playing the role of Carrington
family major domo Joseph Anders I know
I'm going to regret asking this but what
exactly is going on Dale got his start
on the popular Australian soap opera
neighbours beginning in 1985 and made
two subsequent guest appearances on the
show in 2018 and 2019 you know I have a
real chance now a giant the lovely giant
the death of Special Agent Michelle Lee
was a shocker played by actress Lisa
Lapera Lee served on the major case
response team
she was hiding quite the secret she was
a mole who was constantly leaking
classified and sensitive information
when the truth is discovered she
confesses later on in the episode Lise
sacrifices herself to stop her handler
Ted Bengston from escaping he uses her
as a human shield and she gives Gibbs
the signal to shoot through her Lapera
has appeared in quite a few films since
leaving the show she played Sophie trend
in the 2009 film Fast and the Furious
and memorably portrayed smart-alecky Liz
in Crazy Stupid Love
more recently Lapierre played Mia in the
Netflix series unbelievable based on the
true story of two female detectives
investigating an assault case played by
Muse Watson Michael Franks is the man
who mentored Gibbs and he was an
invaluable member of the NCIS team
unfortunately Frank's wound up being
brutally stabbed by a serial killer
outside of Gibbs house Watson is set to
appear in the horror film the dead ones
and he's landed a role on the upcoming
miniseries Diary of a lunatic a
follow-up to the film Diary of a lunatic
truths calling in 2005 Lauren Holly
joined the cast of NCIS as Jenny Shepard
the new director of NCIS the character
is subsequently killed off in the season
5 episode judgement day part 1 after
she's cornered by gun-toting assassins
in an abandoned diner she doesn't
survive the encounter but at least she
proves to be exceedingly difficult to
kill
following her exit from the show Holly
was cast as dr. Betty Rogers on the
mystery series motive a stent that began
in 2013 and ended in 2016
she also plays the troubled Lynne Harper
in the third season of designated
survivor played by Matt Jones net Dorna
gets time with the NCIS team didn't last
long
but he was an integral part of the crew
for several seasons the character died
valiantly as he tried to lead hotel
guests to safety following a bomb threat
unfortunately that threat wasn't an
empty one during it may no longer be
with us but Joan's career is certainly
alive and kicking
since 2013 he's played the lovable bad
boy Baxter on the critically acclaimed
series mom it's safe to say this is much
lighter fare than NCIS make a habit of
burying money in my backyard do ya Jones
is also featured in the wacky TV show
let's get physical and in 2019 he
memorably reprised his role as badger in
El Camino a Breaking Bad movie in March
2014
Lucas black made his first appearance as
special agent Christopher LaSalle on
NCIS then in September of that year he
began his long-running stint on spinoff
series NCIS New Orleans and quickly
became a fan favorite but in season six
LaSalle was unceremoniously shot while
trying to avenge the death of his
brother
no some fans are worried that NCIS New
Orleans won't feel like the same show
without black he was an absolutely a
central part of the series some viewers
suspected he left because of bad blood
behind the scenes but the truth is
actually far less dramatic than that
it sounds like black just wants to spend
more time with his family there's a lot
of priorities in my life that gets
sacrificed for me to be here but it's
time for me to focus on those priorities
as for what acting gigs are in his
future we'll just have to wait and see
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]